the mother of dragons are the mother of
all surprises on the last ever episode
of Game of Thrones and the actress who
plays her has got something to say about
the show's final heartbreaking twist
season ever okay no not that anyway
spoilers from here on out I'll tell you
everything in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly Daenerys Targaryen
star Emilia Clarke broke her silence on
the finale admitting to the public that
she was in a state of total disbelief
after reading the scripts for season 8
Clarke had just finished shooting solo a
Star Wars story in October of 2017 when
she learned that the character she had
played for almost a decade would die at
the hands of her lover during the show's
final episode she touched down at
Heathrow Airport in London and
completely freaked out when she received
the scripts electronically nearly
leaving her suitcases that he throws
baggage claim because she was so eager
to get home and find out what would
happen it during the show's final
episode about points Clarke have yet to
face the facts with the neurosis
downfall when she did however she was
beside herself she told Entertainment
Weekly I got myself situated I got my
cup of tea I had to physically prepare
the space in them again reading them
excitement turned to anguish as Clarke
learned of the events that led to
Downey's devastating death that
desperate fight against the undead the
deaths of her closest friends and allies
the loss of a second dragon and
eventually the destruction of King's
Landing at a hand having lost nearly
everything Danny finally reaches the
Iron Throne only to lose it all in a
moment it took hours for Clarke to
settle back into herself after the
revelation she explained I cried and I
went for a walk
I walked out of the house and took my
keys and phone and walked back with
blisters on my feet I didn't come back
for five hours I'm like how am I gonna
do this because it comes out of being no
we're learning that Daenerys would turn
dark had joined the final two episodes
of Game of Thrones then be killed by a
man she truly loved hit a number on
Clarke whose emotions ran high as she
tried to process everything she said I
called my mom and said I read the
scripts and I don't want to tell you
what happens but you just taught me off
this ledge it really messed me up
despite being shoved out of her mind
about the events of the show's finale
Clarke noted that the ending Danny got
was the one that made the most sense for
character she explained after ten years
of working on the show it's logical
where else can she go I try to think
what the ending will be it's not like
she's suddenly going to go
okay I'm gonna put a kettle on and put
cookies in the oven and we'll just sit
down and have a lovely time and pop a
few kids out that was never going to
happen she's a Targaryen Clark added
that she felt daddy's conclusion served
as a full-circle moment for the naive
young woman viewers met on the first
season of Game of Thrones she said it's
a very beautiful and touching ending
hopefully what you'll see in that last
moment as she's dying is there's the
bomb ability there's a little girl you
met in season one see she's right there
and now she's not there anymore Game of
Thrones final season will likely go down
in history as incredibly divisive and
hugely disappointing to some but no
matter whether you loved our Game of
Thrones ended or not there's no denying
at the end of the show's journey as well
as Danny's won't be forgotten anytime
soon check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about Game of Thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]